in his new book suicide of the West
national reviews Jonah Goldberg talks of
what he calls the miracle the immense
and ongoing increase in human wealth
health freedom and longevity assured in
during the Enlightenment and Industrial
Revolution a turn sounding like Karl
Marx Joseph Schumpeter an economist
Deirdre McCloskey Goldberg writes in a
free market money corrodes cast in class
and lubricates social interaction
capitalism is the most cooperative
system ever created for the peaceful
improvement of people's lives it has
only a single fatal flaw it doesn't feel
like it in a wide-ranging conversation
with reason
Goldberg talks about his new book how
his thinking has evolved on a number of
culture war issues and why he can't just
admit once and for all that he's
becoming a libertarian Jenna Goldberg
thanks for talking to reason hey it's
great to be here me in suicide of the
West you talked about the miracle right
describe the miracle I call it the
miracle because logic us it's
inexplicable when something hugely
providential and wonderful happens that
you can't explain we call it a miracle
and one of the things that I was struck
by when I started working on the book
was there was this remarkable consensus
that for sort of the Deidra McCloskey
thesis I'm deeply indebted to her that
for 200 3,000 years the average human
being everywhere in the world lived on
about three dollars a day or less right
and then once and only once in all human
history it starts to change
unbelievable consensus about this from
the hard left of the hard right everyone
sort of agrees on those numbers to one
extent or another when it comes to the
question of why it happened all
consensus breaks where it happened
because I mean then you go through and
you know and I have to say as a kind of
like globalist libertarian nice I mean
like you know it used to be that well
the Industrial Revolution happened and
like the Enlightenment or whatever you
want to call it this massive rise in
living standards of course it happened
in the West because we speak English in
the way we're British or you know we
have PBS or something and it's yeah I
mean you talk about like it didn't have
to happen here that's right so it
happened it I argue it happened in
England right
McClosky makes a good argument that it
could have also you also could serve say
it started in Holland and every now and
then I hear from some Dutch jingoist
juices nose Holland whatever
but for I think the better cases be
adrenaline but obviously there was
cross-pollination yeah right but it only
happened once at least in the sustained
way that you could point to the root you
know the Republic of Venice you can
point to these various only checks had
had their moment that's right lad yeah
but almost always when things start to
go like this
there was this regression back to the
mean the Mount logical Malthusian ISM
something kicked in I tend to believe it
it had to do with the the the
powers-that-be circled the wagons
crushed innovation you know the Chinese
call back the ships they killed the
steel mills that kill the printing press
because innovation was threatening to
this to the powers that be to the status
quo and but for some reason and I think
McCloskey is largely not entirely
largely persuasive on this what causes
the miracle isn't some specific public
policy or anything like that it's words
it's language it's the Lang it's a story
we tell ourselves about ourselves for
thousands of years in Western Europe
innovation was considered a sin the sin
of Karakas questioning the established
order and then all of a sudden
innovation from the ground up starts
bubbling up this idea that the sort of
Lockean idea doesn't come from law but
locke represents it that the fruits of
our labors belong to us that if you can
build a better mousetrap you should reap
the rewards of that and it has this
explosive effect that that spreads out
across the world and part of my argument
is that it's not this is this very
annoying debate about whether it's the
Enlightenment or not right and I don't
think there's any one enlightenment the
reason I call it the miracle because it
includes all of the quirky weirdness of
English culture which was not
necessarily about the Enlightenment
right but but also includes you know the
convergence of things like the
Scientific Revolution enlightenment
principles the Industrial Revolution all
of these things converged once and only
once but my point of bringing it up is
that it's unnatural if it were natural
if this was how human beings just
automatically self-organized into
prosperous communities of rule of law an
individual autonomy it would have
occurred a little earlier in the
evolutionary record then 250,000 years
after we split off from the animals what
are the attributes that we need to
preserve of the miracle and
I mean the book is suicide of the West
had the rebirth of tribalism populism
nationalism and identity politics is
destroying American democracy so I've
just given you the list of that you
wrote at length but you know what it
what is the essential insight that needs
to be preserved and then when you say
we're committing suicide is it is it
suicide or is it homicide I mean is it
is it a self death or is it being
imposed on us the working title of the
book for a couple years was the tribe of
Liberty and which would have been more
conducive to my friends at reason
probably and the basic argument that I
wanted that I make that I want that I
was sort of centered on was this idea
that we need to rekindle this sort of
tribal pre rational commitment to the
institutions of Liberty because one of
those is where I think you're Juma class
geek falls a little short is her
dismissiveness towards the institutional
theory of development right and that
there are institutions but both in the
sort of economic sense of just rules but
also actually physical you know
organizations groups traditions that
inculcate and civilize us and make us
respect and admire and and want to
preserve Liberty and those things are
often taught to us in a pre rational way
right they're taught to us when we're
born into any family that have a
commitment to certain ideas and we have
to be taught those things and but it's
weird we have to be taught pre rational
kind of identity I mean it I mean it
becomes complicated really quickly
that's because the whole point one of
the reasons we were able to get rich and
and not just get rich but I mean rich in
the sense of committing to an order
where we may not win right this like
part of what central to both Deirdre is
that's right argument as well as yours
is that like in a businessmen as well as
leaders are willing to say hey you know
what I'm gonna open myself up to an
election either in a marketplace or
whatever and I might not win but then
you know you abstract that out that's
kind of science and rationality but then
you're talking about you know how do you
have a tribe that is at like that is pre
rational like an identity towards
something that you know it seems like
the pre rational is is always going to
be
opposed to that one of my favorite lines
is Hana and says every generation
Western civilization is invaded by
barbarians we call them children right
and so we come with all sorts of factory
pre-loaded software in us but that
software is unchanging over millennia
for the most part right so a baby born a
Viking Age transported today you raise
it a nice family from New Rochelle it
becomes an orthodontist right but if you
take the baby from New Rochelle send it
back it grows up to be a pull under the
English countries right right so we're
born into families you know there's this
argument that can't remember the guy who
says that there's his argument that um
you know modernity was was born in 11th
century England by a nun who basically
explains that you can't marry your
cousins anymore
and that's how the nuclear family kind
of emerges as a fundamental unit of
English culture so I'm a big believer
that they I do think that the the
nuclear family obviously by the way
that's not Rudy Giuliani no that is not
- or or our the our dear leader
president and and so I do think they're
all you know look one of the things that
binds Hayek McCloskey lots of the sort
of the more Berkey and libertarians is
this idea that capitalism depends upon
values that it cannot create and cannot
restore once lost right and so one of
the things this huge influence on me is
Friedrich Hayek's fatal conceit where he
has the microcosm and the macrocosm
right the microcosm is the world of
intimate relationships right the world
first of all family but also friendships
community and the rules there are not
market rules right you know as I often
say in my family I'm a communist all
right if you have two kids and one kid
is really skilled and talented and the
other kid really isn't you don't say
well he doesn't get the operation right
you are you gonna flip and tell us which
kid is which no no what I only have one
kid so but my point is is that in the
family you got rid of the loser yeah
well you went on ice for yeah but um no
my point is is that within the family it
really is from each according to his
ability to
according to his need I don't put price
tags on the film in the fridge and all
that the way what Hayek argues is that
that it's the microcosm that generates
the values the respect for human rights
the respect for human dignity the
respect for the golden rule all of these
sorts of yeasty cultural ideas that make
the macrocosm of the extended order of
Liberty work and and the extended order
of Liberty which is the world of
contracts of consumers of rule law it
lowers the the threshold to dealing with
strangers right because in the state of
nature the way you deal with the
stranger is you hit him over the head
with a rock and the way in the modern
world we deal with a stranger is we try
to sell them rocks or something else
right and it's a part of my argument
which is the one of the constants going
back to my first book liberal fascism is
that if you ever - if you every attempt
of - every kind of totalitarian regime
or authoritarian regime is trying to
take the values of the microcosm and
apply them to the macrocosm we're all
one family right we're all you know it
not to use them as tribalism from one
race fascism the tribalism for one
country communism is travels in one
class it is trying to take those sorts
of notions of social solidarity and
intimacy of the microcosm and apply them
to the macrocosm and when you do that
you destroy Liberty in the rule of law
however when you take the logic of the
macrocosm and you apply it to the
microcosm you destroy the the engines of
value generation that make that work
right if you treat we try to turn every
family into a business right it would
ruin the family yeah and if you try to
make the country of 310 million people
operate as if the president were our
Father or our mother right it would ruin
everything the reason stands for and
everything that we stand for when you
talked about how like you know there's a
story that we tell ourselves and it's
kind of if we you know if we tell it
long enough and it's a good story and it
yields good results we continue to tell
it right what are the stories that we're
telling ourselves that are different
from you know when when do you date and
I'm struggling to recall in the book but
when do you did when do you date the
decline or the beginning of the suicide
cuz yeah and this is a slow-motion
suicide right and again a lot of it is
all figurative right because yeah of
course part of my
you know getting back to the Hana iron
thing or what Ronald Reagan said is you
know every generation we're only one
generation away from tyranny because we
don't inherit a love for liberty in our
blood we have to be taught it right so
we've had these struck we've had these
struggles many times in our past you
look in the 1930s you'd argue the
struggle was worth it took a different
form the arguments were different but
there was this idea about you know
communism or statism or fascism
collectivism whatever you want to call
it
those were live propositions in the
1930s in the West and they succeeded to
take over vast chunks of Europe you know
you're talking about the 30s and
collectivism okay so is that the
beginning of the end in every generation
there are fuses lit that could lead to
the end and in every generation there
are successes and putting out some of
the fuses you know and so I think that
one of the places one of the places
where this transition is coming from
that I've focused on quite a bit is it's
not so much you know
should the government be this big or
this big or this big right but how is
the story we're telling ourselves about
ourselves changing so one of the things
I focus on and it's most acute in higher
education but watch virtually any
freaking award show from you know how to
Hollywood you find it there too you find
it in mainstream journalism is this
desire to sort of define all of
Americans cysts all of American history
by its sins right and I want to teach
that stuff absolutely want to teach
about slavery I want to teach about the
bad things that came with Christopher
Columbus what we did to the Indians we
did some terrible things right
you're not saying like okay we have to
teach you know Christopher Columbus was
the greatest guy no we're all the less
than that and then you know George
Washington cherry trees I mean it's a
thick history and a recognition of where
we failed one of the things that drives
me absolutely crazy is our tendency the
sort of historicist Whiggish tendency
tendency to compare events in the past
towards an ID against an ideal in the
future right the American Founding has
all sorts of problems with it but it was
better than anything that came before it
right and yet what we want to do
we want to hold up the gold standard of
not even today but an ideal sometime in
the utopian future against what they
were talking about in 1776 and so for
example you know take slavery you know
slavery was abundantly evil we know that
and the founding fathers great sin other
than the actual institution of slavery
itself was the hypocrisy about it right
it's one thing in an absolute monarchy
to have slavery well everyone's sort of
the kings live anyway right it's another
thing when a country is founded on a
proposition that says all men are
created equal and endowed certain
inalienable rights to have slavery or
not allow women to vote or all that kind
of right but and then also and I think
youyou point this out not and then the
twist on slavery is that the children of
slaves are themselves slaves that's
right so it's like we even added like a
deeper turn of hypocrisy that's right
that is that is one of the truly great
horrors of it right the old Roman model
was no man is born a slave no man is
born a slave but he can be turned into
one right but your slaves kids are free
right the and one of the things I got
this largely from Michael Munger one of
the things that the southerners had to
do when that argument was no longer
convenient is switch to the old Greek
Aristotelian argument which said that
some people just slaves by Nature right
but the point of the point I'm getting
at is that the hypocrisy was this
incredible gift because you can't be a
hypocrite without an ideal without
principles right it's only by one of the
things that hypocrisy does is it it
illuminates the principle and and it
creates a sort of dialectic process by
which you have to examine how you're
going back to fact your first book I
mean you're like a total Marxist 19th
century I think a much more I like
and you know but and III agree with you
in the right direction so so why does
where when do you date then this idea
that we stopped focusing on okay the
imperfections but we're moving towards
an ideal or were maybe not and you have
a great line in the in the book where
you write teleology is an antidote to
despair in nihilism which it absolutely
is a daily ology the idea that we're
moving inexorably toward some end point
when does when does this shift happen
for you in American culture where we
stop saying okay you know what we're
like we're [ __ ] or you know we're
we're imperfect but we're moving towards
a better place to we are only always
failing our best you know the better
yeah in question um and maybe it doesn't
matter really yeah I don't know I mean
uh matters because it's interesting
question so even right there it says
some worth to me well and you know in
the in the eighties certainly and I'm
thinking back to somebody like William
Bennett he in one of the greatest kind
of slights of hand he he said it was the
sixties and not the fifties but then if
you go back and you look at the American
kind of cultural history of sociology
and whatnot it was like now the fifties
is the minute that we got fat and happy
after you have decades of depression and
war like we started going downhill but
so where where do you date it or is it
just a consistent strain well I mean
that is now dominant I think it's more
that I think it's more that there are
certain arguments that become more
appealing when the materials not as not
more Marxist that yeah but here this is
great exchange between William F Buckley
and Whittaker Chambers after a chambers
switches to what he thought was gonna be
the losing side right and he said he
refuses to call himself a conservative
because he can't let go of his distill
Marxism and so I call himself a man of
the right but he holds up this thing
that he calls the Beaconsfield position
which is named after a Benjamin Disraeli
it was their role of Biggins people and
he basically argues that at the end of
the day the thing that drives history is
technology and the means of production
and ideas flow from that
I hate to say it I'm more sympathetic to
that in the night marks that you know
the death of Karl Hess yeah absolutely
know that the you know the steam engine
gives us democracy right you know and
mark says Marcos is the cotton gin right
gives us capitalism yeah yeah and that
the feudal system was an outgrowth of
the means of production I mean let the
cultural superstructure is based on the
economic you know base yeah and so one
so one of the arguments that I would
make is that just you have a pin in this
is that one of the great and glorious
things about the American Revolution and
the the constitutional convention is
that a lot of those ideas that emerge
from the miracle which let's remember
worked right I mean this bourgeois
mercantile merchant class ideology made
poor people richer
I also made rich people richer but if
you're on the progressive mindset and
says the things should be concerned
about is the status of poor people this
is the only economic system that has
actually made people richer and we
should recognize that and the great
thing about the American Founding is
they wrote this [ __ ] down right and kind
of locked us into it and because of the
cultural stock of the population in the
American Founding and throughout much of
the 19th century
it got instantiated and strengthened in
our institutions and and so I do think I
would probably say that this starts to
really start to unravel not in 1960s not
in 1950s but really with the rise of the
Progressive Era where you get all of
these major intellectuals who basically
are taught from the historicist school
in Germany that come to the United
States and they think everything is
relative
they think that they completely reject
you know the I don't want to say proxy
ology but you know the views of the
Austrian school and all that kind of
stuff and they say that all cultures I
think I'm falling in love right last
time I saw you know I use proxy ology in
the conversation it was I think with
myself
do you smoke a cigarette afterwards yeah
and so those ideas long simmered and so
many of the ideas as you know for my
first book I basically consider the New
Deal to be the
a culmination of the Wilson
administration right and basically all
of 20th century progressivism is a play
on the ideas that I think start
essentially William James with the moral
equivalent of war and run straight
through where we're gonna have we're
gonna be nationalists but what I'm gonna
call ourselves nationalistic we're gonna
call it those progressivism pragmatic
but we are going to sort of Bend the
people to rally together in social
solidarity as if we were at war but for
that war and those sort of ideas
percolating they start taking over the
universities and then the materialist
part comes in after World War two where
we get really rich really fast and the
problem with it I like getting rich
really fast and I want to make the world
get richer really fast but the the
violence that does to establish
institutions and customs and norms sets
a lot of people adrift and and you get
and this gets me to Schumpeter you get a
mass affluent class of people whose
careers and professional outlook are
what he calls the new class where they
are incentivized and professionalized to
peon America from a great height and to
peon capitalism from a great height and
argue and now in Schumpeter gets a lot
of this stuff from Nietzsche's genealogy
of morals they're the priests who want
to use the only weapons they have which
are words concepts and undermine the
system of capitalism and argue for
something that empowers them and this is
I mean the genius of Schumpeter who was
I mean capitalism socialism and
democracy which I think came out 42 and
it's through the your book fantastic
read I mean it said it's not really the
liberation Marx was right that
capitalism would destroy itself but not
because of the immiseration of the
working-class I know they would revolt
but rather that people get kind of fat
and happy and they they they tend to you
know they have nothing but anger and ire
towards the system that produces more
stockings for factory girls than the
Queen's right so yeah robber barons yeah
who have lawyers for kids and the
lawyers have spoken word poets from kids
right now and what's amazing about this
so I mean in a way the suicide of the
web
it's kind of like a luxury good right
it's that's right we've we're finally we
don't have to worry about food we don't
have to worry about even like next
week's budget that's what we start to
turn on ourself well but but that's true
particularly for the upper classes right
I mean this is a part of how Marx gets
turned on his head you know in the
Communist Manifesto workers of the world
unite which was idiotic because a
working-class guy in Milan wasn't gonna
have a feeling of social solidarity with
a working-class guy from Kiev but he
might for a fellow you know Italian
right what we're witnessing because of
this level of mass affluence is it's the
ruling classes of the world that are
uniting I mean I don't want to go all
Steve Bannon because they think he's a
Stygian force in American life but it is
this literally that's what
cosmopolitanism means right and so you
get these people who the globalist class
who have more sense of social connection
with somebody across the Atlantic who
shares their status than they do with
the person who cleans their yard let's I
mean let's talk about this the way and
you mentioned ban and you and National
Review I think two national reviews
credit and you know like you put it on
the line you were like [ __ ] Trump I mean
early on from the right I mean like you
attacked him and have maintained that
while also not becoming delusional I
mean there's some things that Trump is
doing that are good right but so you
have Bannon and Trump and Trump is
nothing if not a cosmopolitan right he's
a billionaire and he hangs out and
urinates on mattresses all and every
time even Antarctica and you know but
these are the guys who are saying like
you're being like how does this play out
in a world where the Cosmopolitan's and
the globalists the rich people are
saying you you know a former factory
worker in an upper Wisconsin are being
sold a good buy globalist like how what
what's going on that they're the ones
who are the most tribal now part of the
reason why I think we're in the shitty
position that we're in is and this is a
point I get from charles murray is that
our elites will not preach what they
practice this the most of the six the
I don't know what the top 5% 10%
whatever it is the divorce crisis has
ended for them 30 years ago right rich
people tend to live pretty booze wah
lives you know we all know the outliers
right but in Steve Bannon being one of
them you know he's just got more layers
than one of his ensembles but most
successful people in this country wait
till they get as much education as they
can then they get married then they have
kids and it turns out if you follow that
basic booze wah kind of lifestyle if
you're gonna try at high school without
you know either fathering or mothering
or siring a child like you're gonna do
it you're gonna do okay right but you
know this is something that toddler
calendars written about a peg is written
about that the the bonus the economic
gains from marriage or in some cases
greater than and often equal to the
gains from going to college but it's
part of the Gestalt of sort of the new
class not to tell people to get married
right it's going you have to go to
college you know they love talking about
going to college but they feel like it's
too judgey to say maybe you should get
married and I think this is one of the
examples of how our elites don't are
sort of contemptuous of the values that
got them rich and they they're terrified
of preaching them to other people in
terms of the band and sort of globalist
thing
look III think in the case of Bannon and
all you guys it is difficult to
exaggerate the level of cynicism
involved in a lot of this and the the
irony of Donald Trump being the leader
of the Family Values Coalition is not
lost on me and I think part of it has to
do with the fact that as these other
institutions that help civilize
barbarians of civil society of Church of
community of you know civic association
as those atrophy a lot of people are
retreating to people who only agree with
them and they're also retreating to
virtual communities which are just not
as good as real communities and one of
the things that the neuroscientists have
sort of demonstrated is that when you
retreat out of the real world and
go into the Facebook world you first of
all have almost all of your um your
prejudices confirmed because you're only
looking for your car keys where the
light is good right you're only looking
for people who are gonna say you didn't
you're right but you didn't go far
enough right and they're turning
everybody into [ __ ] and we're
watching politics like it's
entertainment and this is one of the
things that Steven Pinker is really good
on and how the brain how the mind works
most of your brain doesn't understand
you're watching entertainment when
you're watching entertainment you know
when you watch a movie most of your
brain thinks the hero really is running
through the shopping mall shooting
people or whatever it is right there's a
little part of your rational brain does
but the part that makes you engage you
jump out of your seat all that kind of
stuff that's your brain thinking this
stuff is real not just pixels on a
screen and the problem is when you start
watching politics like it's
entertainment you stop actually caring
about the policy and instead you just
care about my guy winning and your guys
your guy that's losing and you get into
this sort of asinine your tears are
delicious kind of stuff which look I do
I've done plenty of that stuff in my
life
there's a place for it but I never
argued that doing bad things or stupid
things was justifiable or worthwhile as
long as you own the libs right and
that's where we are now we're on both
sides both on the right and the left
because we've we've bought into this
sort of tribal understanding that it's
just a zero-sum thing our heroes need to
win there guys need to lose that we no
longer actually care about the
functioning of govern so you know and
and here's well two things one do you
think Trump is ultimately demystifying
this and and I remember when when
National Review came out against Trump I
was like you know it's kind of weird
because Trump was espousing particularly
on immigration
essentially what National Review have
been preaching for decades really you
know that we need to stop the flow of
Mexicans and they you know they can't be
turned into Americans and things like
that and then it's like oh my god like
he's he's the enemy do you think he's
demystifying that and say you know we're
coming off the the hot news cycle of the
families being you know pulled apart you
know
but you know suckling babies being
ripped from their mothers breasts on a
lot of levels is trumped the end of this
I mean because he's showing us what
we've been telling ourselves you know
through our electoral process and
through some of our rhetorical excesses
this is what we want to certain ascend I
think so I mean oh we can get into the
weeds about yeah the immigration
positions of National Review versus
Donald Trump no one a National Review
liked what he had to say but the judge
Curie all right yeah sure a lot of that
stuff right we all thought the Muslim
BAM thing was idiotic but I want see all
but I'm pretty sure all at least you did
so yeah well I don't know anyway that
said you know my position has long been
that Trump is not the author of all of
our problems
he's a symptom of our problems right but
he's making a lot of those problems much
worse right Orwell has this line where
he says a man can feel himself a failure
and take to drink and become all the
more failure because he drinks America
can be [ __ ] up
and and I like Donald Trump get more
attacked not to cause that's right I'm
that's for sure and but then is this you
know does he also offer us you know and
in a lot of ways he's the do you know
he's the end of a long twentieth century
I mean he's hopeful II he's the last
baby boomer president he's the yeah he
and Hillary Clinton and Bernie Sanders
all hate the gig economy they write you
know they hate anything new and
different I mean he doesn't even use
email which may help him in the long run
yeah or at least in the you know in
legal status but it's closing out you
know that world I mean by showing what
it really is like I don't think so I
have a much more dyspeptic and dire
interpretation I think what Trump has
done is break the blood-brain barrier
between politics and entertainment in a
way that will not be repaired for a very
long time I was saying in 2016 you know
as late as July that if Tom Hanks or you
know Oprah or one of those guys
parachuted in they could have probably
won the election because everyone hated
Hillary and everyone aidid Trump I mean
no I mean both parties managed to
nominate the one candidate had a chance
of losing to the other right
it was a choice between two different
crab sandwiches on different kinds of
bread right but it was delicious bread
it was entertaining bread yes and and so
I think this you know this I used to
tell I was telling us at the time you
know this is a bigger problem for the
laughter than it is for the right
because our bench of celebrities Peters
out around Scott Baio you know then we
got Ted Nugent that's about it right and
and they've got this huge deep bench and
what Trump has proved is that you can
have a completely thumbless grasp on the
Constitution you can have you can
encourage members that your rally is to
commit violence against people you can
save the most despicable things and so
long as you're entertaining and as so
long as you and then let's give let's be
fair
Trump has this lizard brain genius for
you know it's like a sci-fi character
who manages to project what's going on
in his head and make the world bend to
it and so you see Democrats but clowning
themselves constantly because they feel
they have to operate within the universe
of a reality show logic and it really
does feel like every year the writers of
our reality are just getting more and
more desperate and bringing back old
characters and doing Brian crazy [ __ ]
and I think that that's what Trump is
doing and I don't know that you write
the ship too quick so let's you know if
we go with the idea that he's the effect
he's kind of like the terminus maybe and
maybe not he's just like you know we're
midway down this road but you talked
about the institutions that have kind of
lost their cultural power and this is
something if you look at Gallup or you
look at any kind of long-term surveys
the amount of trust and confidence in
the government in the various parts of
government but also the private sector
big business small business philanthropy
you know everything except the military
and occasionally cops right and and that
those can vary right and it's it's clear
that people like the individuals but
they you know nobody is a fan of
American foreign policy small business
small business does okay military does
pretty good cops are just above so water
what do we do
you know what are the ways and and you
were saying earlier like okay you know
like we lose that confidence we lose the
trust and that's it it's gone
is there a teleology that doesn't lead
to you know you you wrote it's an
antidote to the sparrin nihilism what
are the ways that and maybe it's not
teleology but like how do we reinvest
institutions or create new ones that I
are actually worthy of our trust and
confidence because it is true you know
starting certainly you know and it's
easy reasons and it's fifties here we
started in 1968 like you you if you
start from 1968 the government has only
been lying to us more about big things
and small things where was Vietnam and
why we got in to surveillance in the in
the 70s it cetera like you know where
it's incompetence how do we reinvest
these institutions with something like
trust and confidence that they actually
right so it's a NICU and I go back to at
least 20 years right we've been on many
panels talking about conservatism for
libertarianism right and I've never been
on one of these panels I don't think
we're you know we're talking about where
do we have shared agenda where do we
differ all the kind of stuff and
sometimes they're hostile sometimes
they're not
sometimes we pregame too much whatever
um there's always some 21 year old punk
smartass kid who during the Q&A says all
this is very interesting but isn't it
true that if we could just go back to
the federal structure Federalist
structure that the founders envisioned
where local communities had more power
over their own lives wouldn't that sort
of solve most of these disagreements
because it's only when you have a
national idea when you're when you have
a one nation politics and everyone wants
to impose their values right there's no
right to excess like at a Hirshman
Albert Hirschman thing yeah you where
where are you gonna go that's right and
there's not a lot of policy prescription
in the book but one of the things I
think that screams out from it is just
simply this idea of pushing as much
power down to the most local level
possible I think some of the paranoia
about globalists is [ __ ]
I think some of it is totally fair and
some of it is
but understandable right and you have to
take these complaints on a case-by-case
basis but one thing that's indisputable
is there is a widespread view that
either Washington or some other powers
that be are making too many decisions
about our own lives and if you push
power down to the most local level
possible you get all of these benefits
first of all you still have mistakes you
still have communities doing stupid
things right you can't camp from Bexley
every camping wreck Jim Crow we amended
the constitutions we had a civil war
that's done right it's a settled
question but if one community wants to
you know banned stinky cheese let them
but why does the FDA have to do it right
and you push these things down most
local level possible one of the benefits
you get is that people know who the
powers that be are they know their names
they see them at the grocery store they
seen with their kids events and it it
gives you a sense of you know who's
accountable
moreover you still have culture war
fights but the winners have to look at
the losers in the eye the next day and
that breeds a certain sense of humility
it breeds a certain sense of live to
fight another day and it gets but
instead what we have is these National
coalition's these tribal idiotic
coalition's that want to impose one way
of living for the entire country so
Libya you know you've mentioned Hana
aren't good and you know is that what
the Trump voter and it's not you know I
don't think that the Trump voter is like
the problem in America necessarily but
are they you know do they want to have
responsibility for their lives because
you're right you know on a certain level
you know it's clear like global trade
policy changes things and it changes the
economy and things like that but I've
lived you know at least half time for
twenty years in a small town and I don't
you know on a certain level I like
coming to Washington in New York because
I don't have to look the people who are
running my life in the eye
you know there's anonymity there and
there's a freedom I remember the column
got in a lot of trouble but 15 years ago
on this
yeah city air makes you free yeah well
and it's but you know so like you know
is is that what people I mean are you is
is the American you know again using
these ridiculous abstractions I mean are
they suffering from a lack of
responsibility for their lives or are
they actually running towards whether
it's Hillary Clinton or Donald Trump or
Bernie Sanders or Joe Biden or whoever
they're running from there it's an
escape from freedom you know to use oh
it is from or something no I think
that's a I think that's exactly right I
mean look I mean I'm I have no problem
giving the people their fair share of
blame right the Democrats are very good
at this and they were doing it for far
longer this promise that the government
can love you right that the government
can take care of you that's the life of
Julia [ __ ] right that's the the
opening sentence from the Democratic
convention in 2012 which said the
government is the one thing we all
belong to right which is yeah free plug
right you know that million levels but
the people who hear that don't hear you
know yeah that they hear belong to feel
like they're part of right that's the
politics of meaning stuff that already
Clinton used to talk about and what
happens when you feel powerless in your
own alienated deracinated you know the
little corner of suburban America where
you don't have many social connections
or I mean so or the inner city right you
start you don't lose what Robert Nizza
been called the quest for community you
just start looking elsewhere for it and
your gaze says you can't find it and
then in the near ground your gaze looks
to it the far ground you start looking
to Washington and politic you know that
the government is the one thing we all
belong to line I'm sure was focus group
to death and their enormous number of
people who feel like they want to belong
to some Servet of and and liberals or
whatever so you know how do you how do
you grow and you say okay we push power
down a political power say down to the
lowest level possible that's that's all
well and good but how do you
teleology is an answer to gas baron
nihilism and and also group belonging
like how you know on a basic level like
how does that play out in a way that
does not immediately turn to the worst
kinds of tribal instincts that you
document in the book and let you say are
destroying America I mean or that are as
part of the suicide what is the positive
way of local belonging as well as kind
of also understanding you know that you
can belong to this is the thing about
Trump that it's always driven me mad is
the idea that like I grew up in
Middletown New Jersey I love Middletown
New Jersey and I also want to be a
rootless Cosmo cosmopolitan I don't see
any distinction between being a citizen
of the world and some you know jerk who
grew up in New Jersey how do you how do
you create that person who is not a
bully who is not a tribe member it was
like okay you know what Jonah Goldberg
and Nikhil SP were basically we grow you
know we were born in New York but you're
Jewish and I'm Irish and Italian so we
have to [ __ ] hate each other like you
know how do you do that what are the
institutions and if it's the stories
we're telling ourselves in higher
education and then peeling it back
towards K through 12 or whatever right
how do we tell those stories and how do
we create those Association okay so the
other person I'm deeply indebted to is
Douglas North who is pure institutional
right and a bell laureate Nobel laureate
and also Ernest Gellner right and so
Ernest Gellner is this historian and
philosopher sort of anthropologist guy
and one of the things the ER uses that
prior to modernity right 1700 like
whatever right all of our identities
were overlapped on each other when you
were in the tribe I mean people under
that fundamentally fascist are the state
of nature was for Humanity we grew up in
a little tribe a little platoon a little
troupe but if you want to call it and
all meaning was it was it was was within
the tribe nothing was without the tribe
right we were all essentially kin we
were all working towards a common good
we were all dedicated through cause
larger than ourselves in effect we
worshiped ourselves we deified ourselves
so we in and so Geller makes this point
was like for pre-modern man when he
did a tree he saw a tree that was a
source of fuel he saw a tree as a source
of shade he saw a tree that was maybe a
spirit that he worshiped and all of
these things were intertwined and
bundled together and what modernity
comes along and does is it starts
dividing up meaning and and it says no
the tree is just this and not these
other things and so one of the things
that I think is the antidote to the the
problems that we have and I think that
the problem that we have our best
identified as as identity politics but
mujin just in different forms is this
idea of singular meaning that all you
need to know about me is Jewish guy
right even though I'm pretty weak taeju
right or all you need to know about a
black person is that they're black it
doesn't matter whether they have a PhD
or they're male or female or the
Christian or Muslim I can reduce all of
them into this narrow car plan
classification and one of the great
things about the sort of the miracle
Liberal Democratic capitalism whatever
you want to do whatever I want to call
it is it allows us to have a multitude
of identities where we have allegiances
to different institutions but they don't
wholly define us and they allow us to
exit one and go into another try on one
leave that one the problem with the
identity politics mindset is it says I
can reduce someone to a singular thing
and when you do that you sort of flip
the switch of the tribe of mine and say
so anybody who isn't me is the enemy
because that's how we're wired and so
what you want to do and one of the
reasons why you know the Douglas noir
thesis is one of the reason why
modernity emerges is that you've got
enough institutions that elites would
cycle through that they had a
sympathetic imagination to institutions
that they didn't necessarily belong to
at a moment and they understood that the
system depended upon allowing winners to
win even if it was not in the moment
good for them we're losing that and one
of the reasons why I think it's it's big
identity politics mindset which is which
breaks my heart is getting more more
popular on the right and has been
instantiated on the left for a very long
time is that we are teaching people that
they can't assimilate that they can't
break out of the iron cage of their
identity look they can't mongrelize and
hybridize here I'd like can I just ask
you point-blank sure are you gonna come
out as a libertarian right now because
what you're talking about is the past 50
years of Reason magazine sort of the
idea of you know and obviously
conservatives and I think one of our
first kind of tussles was over you know
and I had a somewhat pedantic reading of
Hayek's why I'm not a conservative but
it you know it is true that
conservatives trail I mean that's the
idea that they act as an anchor um you
know and that societies need to be
dragged in a particular direction and
one of the functions of conservativism I
think is to say okay let's slow down a
little bit because you don't know from a
high acumen point of view we don't know
where we're going and we might it might
be the French Revolution it might be the
American Revolution right but I mean
what you're saying this is so
fundamentally libertarian even to the
extent that you're quoting Deirdre
McCloskey who is used to beat Donald
McCluskey and National Review and
conservatives more broadly you know and
I'm saying you specifically but you know
are like no you know people who are
transgender are mentally ill why what
could we possibly learn from them and
you now are talking about overlapping
identities and and a movement towards
freedom and self-definition
mongrelization versus purity mmm-hmm
so will you come out as a libertarian
today on reason TV and I won't do it and
do it you know you can run with Bill
weld for president you know I will not
not right now although look I mean but
we talked about multiplicity of
identities you know William F Buckley
wrote a book called you know confessions
of a libertarian Journal I think he was
just trying to sell copies I agree you
know there are many things about which I
am a libertarian on and there are some
things on which I'm a conservative on
and I have I've never understood this
indictment of conservatism in the way
present from Hayek of being dragged
along there is a role to be played for
being the person to sort of say hey wait
a minute right I mean I've all I've
argued for 25 years that no policy no
meeting of policymakers should ever ever
gather or consider a question without a
libertarian in the room right
libertarian will also often be wrong but
the libertarian will always ask the
first question
should we do anything at all and you get
so much groupthink in policymaking
straps where they just assume of course
we got to just do something right and
the libertarian says we'll wait a second
maybe the system itself can fix this and
and that's I think also a very
conservative position I will say since
you brought it up and this is an old you
know the you know tonk war between us
you know Hayek's why I'm not a
conservative is talking about blood and
soil conservatives in Europe he's you
know like demised in these guys and I
agreed that yeah that blood and soil
[ __ ] is seeping into aspects on the
right in ways that really dismay me but
he said that in America America is the
only place in the world where you can
call yourself a conservative and still
be a defender of Liberty because what
we're trying to conserve and defend are
the ideals of a classically liberal
revolution and so I've always thought
the conservatism the fusionist
conservatism was a cousin of the
libertarians and I will point to that I
know if you saw it but I wrote a piece
that was at the 65th anniversary issue
of National Review last year two years
ago because it's three years ago found
in 55 you know I was I was assigned or
self assigned the article of who lost
libertarians because so many you guys
were going the sort of libertarian way
right and getting more and more you know
not the smart ones siding with the you
know the state forcing the Baker to make
the cake as up and as I started thinking
about and reading about it I decided you
know that frames it completely wrong
because in reality the libertarians are
a much older tradition than the
Conservatives and and modern American
conservatism is is arguably the youngest
significant ideological phenomenon in
American politics
I mean socialism is much older obviously
libertarianism goes back to you know
Spencer or Basquiat you go way back
right
and meanwhile Mount American
conservatism basically begins after
World War two
I mean even the old right doesn't look a
lot like modern conservatism or even
modern libertarianism well we're gonna
leave it there and I feel I feel like
we've made some real headway that you
know libertarians always used to be
considered the punk younger brother of
conservatives and our the cousin and
maybe the forefathers yeah yeah we have
been talking with Jonah Goldberg his
latest book is suicide of the West Jonah
thanks for talking
it was great thank you very for reason
I'm Nick Gillespie
[Music]